all right when democrats lose elections
they blame everyone besides themselves
take for example stacey abrams remember
i'm here to tell you that just because
you win doesn't mean you're one
i come from a state where i was not
entitled to become the governor
yeah remember that but this isn't
anything new for the democratic party
it's right seemingly out of hillary
clinton's playbook 2016.
i believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president he knows he knows that there
were a
bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did
really let's expand on that they love to
tell you the democracy is dying and the
republicans won't accept losing but in
reality they're the ones who are killing
it we're learning this from john
durham's investigation who last month
indicted clinton campaign attorney
michael sussman for lying to the fbi
while pushing a phony investigation at
trump's ties to a kremlin link kremlin
link bank what's key about that
sussman's work for the clinton campaign
he didn't tell the fbi where he was
coming from but now new reporting from
real clear politics shows that the
clinton campaign also tried to pressure
president obama's state department and
the c.i.a into investigating yeah even
while the trump's white house term was
underway so they lost the election and
tried to screw up the administration and
while they're doing that they're
undermining america's trust in our
government and i think you know that
joining us now is fox and friends
weekend co-host pete hegsett mr
everything uh pete
this is very interesting paul sperry has
this interesting revelation so sussman
goes gets indicted and people say well
what's the big deal who's michael
sussman tell us why we should care about
this next wrinkle in this investigation
well it turns out as you laid out
michael sussman was just one piece of an
all-out blitz from the clinton campaign
straight from the clinton campaign it
was not just the fbi it was their
mothership the doj it was the state
department it was the c.i.a they were
running false stories
that they knew were false about trump's
ties to a russian bank because what was
happening at the same time brian hillary
clinton's email scandal was raging so
they needed something else so they ran
these false stories about donald trump's
business interest in russia and they
didn't need any of it to be true brian
you know this and this was laid out by
sussman they just needed an
investigation that could then be
reported upon so a reported
investigation which feeds a news cycle
which then the investigators used as
justification and it's a big dust cloud
they used to try to turn donald trump
into a russian agent it was cynical
enough they did it before they continued
it after the campaign uh and this
information we're getting now shows how
widespread it really was it wasn't one
person it wasn't just christopher steele
it just wasn't just michael sussman if
john durham does his job he could
uncover a whole web here so you had
multiple people coming up to the fbi and
cia saying this donald trump he's hooked
up with russia they have for example the
secret hotline they say between moscow
through a russian bank the trump camp
the trump business has a secret hotline
well it turns out the hotline was a
marketing arm and they knew it they knew
it was a red herring but they used that
as more indications leaking that story
to the press to let people think there's
a secret russian plot between the trump
campaign then the trump presidency and
uh and russia and the damage it did to
this country and that administration is
unquantifiable
they don't they don't care about the
damage brian they wanted the white house
and they didn't care about the damage to
the office of the presidency for four
years as they continued it the word you
used red herring brian is the exact word
in the document as described by folks
pushing the conspiracy theory by hillary
clinton they looked at the email address
they knew it was specious they knew it
was tied to marketing they knew it
wasn't a real hotline to russia they
didn't care they knew their buddies in
the media would continue the narrative
and all they wanted was enough to try to
push it across the finish line for them
it didn't work thankfully but when they
talk about democracy dies in darkness
how many days how many minutes how many
columns have been spent at the
washington post of the new york times
covering this very very little it's been
fox news talk radio and real
investigative journalists who have
uncovered this and it's going to have to
be absolutely and there's something else
so that was 2016 then we see 2020. you
had an administration who was just
tarred by this for the four years a
distraction for the country but now you
have now we're in 20 looking at 2022 but
first off in a midterm election without
a lot of thrilling races but one
everyone's fixated on is the
governorship in virginia terry mcauliffe
is supposed to walk to victory take
check out this poll pete we got it one
hour ago glenn younkin has a eight point
lead over terry mcauliffe look at the
difference since october it was 51-46
now it's 53-45 among virginia likely
voters what do you think is the reason
turns out parents believe they should be
in charge of their child's education and
it turns out people who've spent their
life in government usually don't deliver
on the promises you want in your
community they're more interested in say
a bill being delivered for their benefit
in washington dc which has since failed
terry mcauliffe is the personification
of joe biden in virginia he's been a
part of that complex nobody knew who
who who junkin was before this started
but he dialed into virginia issues
listen to virginia parents and it's not
a republican thing to believe parents
should steer their child's education
it's an independent thing and even a
moderate democrat thing they better
watch the polls voter integrity will be
important but a lead like this is
significant in the state of virginia no
doubt absolutely pete and the other
thing to keep in mind he had zero
surrogates none he said i'll do it win
or lose it's gonna be me do you know if
if terry mcauliffe loses you know who
else loses joe biden
barack obama correct stacey abrams jill
biden all put their personal credibility
on the line for terry mcauliffe they all
lose and they go down with the ship pete
i imagine i'm not going to tell you what
to do but you call me all the time to
ask me but i'll say that might be a
topic over the weekend and if you do
call me again on friday that's what i'll
tell you and i'll tell will too you know
brian you know what might be a topic
speaking of losing you're going to lose
your specious lawsuit against bret baer
for walking and standing i'm joining him
in an amicus brief this is true kane
will be my representative maybe uh todd
pyro maybe emily campano my team of
lawyers if you look at where you're
standing right now brian in that studio
m that is pete's place labeled as such
it is i'm joining bret bear's fight
against you your your standing tyranny
will end i cannot believe how i expose
myself just to show a variety to the
viewer i've exposed myself legally but
i'm standing at pete's place almost as
an homage to you but instead it's flown
up in my face pete you can take the gel
out you are done with tv for tonight
thank you brian appreciate it